good morning John this morning I woke up
in a hotel room that smelled like
cigarettes smoke and cleaning fluids
just driving the bo home we do not
always sleep in the nicest hotel room in
the world in that hotel room because it
is a very short walk to YouTube the
place where the majority of people who
make YouTube a thing work I always
expected to be a bigger building than
that I'm here to attend a thing for
people who make and encourage and are
excited about educational video online
and I'm very excited about that stuff
they even let me give a little talk
which was great when I was in the
bathroom I found something that I think
illustrates a point well that you can
like even an extremely established
industry like toilet paper making still
has room for Innovation people do not
seem as excited about this as I was but
they just completely made the rolly
thing obsolete why did we have it in the
first place basically in my talk I argue
that uh making educational video is a
completely different value proposition
for the consumer of that video than
making entertaining video it's just a
different thing and I think it really
has the potential power to
change so I'm very happy to be doing
this with you John and also to be doing
with a lot of other great creators who
you probably know but other people who
are watching this video may not know and
so I wanted to show you some of those
people here they are my name is Derek
Mueller I run a channel called
veritasium which is the element of truth
because see Veritas is the Latin word
for truth and IEM is the traditional
ending for elements so veritasium the
element of Truth my name is is Brady
Haron and I'm a video journalist based
in the United Kingdom and I run several
channels including periodic videos and
number far and 60 symbols and deep sky
videos and Nottingham science and Bible
decks words of the world and food ski
and there's a couple of other ones it's
so nice for there to be someone in the
world with more YouTube channels than me
that really not sound like me you sound
different I sound different so what
happens if the Electoral College is tied
does that sound more like me does that
sound like me there we go that's my
voice I'm by heart have you noticed the
Moon is really Roundy I don't know if
you were here last night um they don't
have Roundy moons in New York is what
I'm saying are you just gonna not tell
me taking videos and I'll just stand
here smiling at you yes that's what I
was going to do introduce yourself my
name is Henry R I make videos they're
called me physics some people watch them
hey Hank Green's camera Michael from BAU
here I'm in San Bruno AKA close to San
Francisco talking to Hank's camera but
I'm imagining that it's his eyes and I'm
looking very deeply into them
and I'm doing
this hey it's me D welcome to smarter
every day and this is who I'm Hank who
are you hi I'm Hank we're going to
stretch this okay hold on let me focus
on it okay all right stretch that okay
okay now we're going to bend it and then
just wad it up we've ruined our spring
oh why did you do that oh man I don't
know let's see if we can fix it oh I can
confirm that's it takes a little bit but
just watch it's
alive whoa that's witchcraft smarter
everyday is going to do a whole video on
that memory spring thing and I'm looking
forward to it so you should subscribe to
his channel and also to viart and Vsauce
and veritas why are there so many v's
and minute physics and all of Brady's
channels so many channels you should
also subscribe to cross course andai
show don't forget about those ones I'm
really happy to be here and I'm really
happy to see that old Industries can
have Innovations but having seen the
perspective of all these amazing
innovators and Educators there is
nothing right now that excites me more
than revolutionizing how we teach and
also what we teach John I honestly think
that we're a part of that Innovation and
I think that we are so lucky to be there
but even more so of course we are lucky
to have a community of people who
support that so thank you to everyone
who does John I'll see you on
Tuesday so deep sky videos if you're
liking this veritasium if you're liking
this yeah but remember it's not all
about looks there's more there's more to
someone than looks all about brains yeah
cuz otherwise Hank wouldn't have so many
subscribers